hey everyone my name is anu kubo and i
will be your instructor for this
blockchain development course all about
querying data on web3 decentralized
applications
in this course you will get an
introduction into indexing and querying
data on the ethereum blockchain and
understand why querying data on
decentralized networks is so different
to what we are used to on the
traditional web goodbye http requests
hello subgraphs we will be doing this
with some explainer sections as well as
some hands-on experience by building
your own querying technology
by the end of this course you will have
the knowledge to query data from the
ethereum mainnet as well as the variety
of chains on the hosted service in order
to build your own decentralized apps
this course is made possible with a
grant from the graph creators of the
tool we will be using in this video but
first let's cover just exactly what
we'll be looking at in this course
first off we are going to start off by
looking at the graph a decentralized
protocol for indexing and querying data
from blockchains this will include why
it was built in the first place and how
to use it
next we will move on to looking at
sub-graphs which are open apis we'll
discuss how subgraphs help you get the
data you need to create and power your
own decentralized applications or d apps
we will then move on to the more
hands-on approach and cover how to build
a sub-graph with a step-by-step tutorial
then move on to how to query a subgraph
from a front-end application and how to
manage your api keys once we have built
a sub-graph it will then be time to put
it to some good use and make some
queries with it using tools such as the
graph explorer which we will go into how
to use together
you will be glad to know that this
course will take a very beginner
approach so if this is your first time
working with blockchain related topics
you are in safe hands
the only prerequisites i ask of you
before starting this course is to have a
basic understanding of javascript
node.js and graphql however if you are
not super familiar with both please have
a go at following along anyway as there
is still plenty to learn without coding
i think
okay
so a very packed course for you today
i'm excited let's get to it as always
please do give us that sub if you like
this video as this is the way this
channel can grow and we can continue to
create free content for everyone in the
freako camp community
so we have already covered what the
graph is a decentralized protocol for
indexing and querying data from
blockchains but why do we need a
protocol for doing so
well
as some of you may or may not know most
of our activity online today happens on
an internet referred to as web 2.
web 2 is widely considered to be an
internet dominated by companies that
provide services in exchange for your
personal data
this was considered the norm until the
introduction of web 3.
web 3 bypasses all the large
corporations and companies that web 2
relies on by communicating in a
peer-to-peer way
with web3 we are no longer relying on
the companies as our central hub for our
services but rather rely on peer-to-peer
protocols
in web 2 users are able to utilize free
services in exchange for their personal
data and in web 3 users pay protocols to
work for them in exchange for self
sovereignty and privacy in other words
web 3 is decentralized and looks a lot
like this
this meant that whatever we built on web
3 is less reliant on centralized
companies whose servers may go down
causing up to crash as one of the many
examples and more reliant on a
distributed network of lots and lots of
individuals
two great examples of this peer-to-peer
networks or in other words decentralized
networks are the ethereum network an
ipfs or the interplanetary file system
network
let's start with ethereum
now what you might not know is that it
is actually very difficult to query data
on the ethereum blockchain directly
this is because so much of what is
stored on the blockchain is stored in a
very complex way
so currently when you want to find a
file on web2 you tell the browser
exactly where to look for the file you
are searching for this location is
essentially your url and this method for
accessing files is called location based
addressing
this works fine until you guessed it the
server where your files are stored goes
offline or hackers manage to take
something down and you can't access your
files anymore
web 3 overcomes this issue with
content-based addressing
this means that with web 3 when
requesting a specific resource you do
not request its location you request
what you are looking for instead and it
is most likely spread all over web 3 and
not just in one location so super safe
but hard to query
so
while you are able to find a specific
thing that you are looking for more
advanced real-world queries and
operations like aggregation search
relationships non-trivial filtering or
other things you are used to doing with
simple structures are just not possible
to get this data you would have to
process every event ever emitted by a
smart contract two phrases we will be
looking at next read the metadata from
ipfs using the token id and ipfs hash
and then aggregate it
even for these types of relatively
simple queries it will take hours or
even days for a decentralized
application running in a browser to get
a response
you could also build out your own server
process the transactions there save them
to a database and build an api endpoint
on top of it all in order to query the
data however this option is resource
intensive needs maintenance presents a
single point of failure and breaks
important security properties required
for
decentralization
this is where the graph comes in the
graph solves this problem by indexing
blockchain data once blockchain data is
indexed the graph creates a sub graph
that can be queried with your standard
graphql api
some graphs are just open apis
the graph knows which data to index for
your sub graph based on something called
your sub graph manifest that you define
so now thanks to the sub graph manifests
and the graph you are able to query data
on the blockchain and our problem is
solved and not only that we can view the
results of our queries in this neat ui
right here let's have a deeper look at
sub graphs and writing subgraph
manifests in the next section
as we mentioned a subgraph manifest also
known as a sub graph description is
something that the graph uses to index
the data that you need on the blockchain
we also mentioned that this is something
that you define yourself
for example you can define a subgraph
manifest to query the smart contracts
you are interested in for a sub graph
the events in those contracts to pay
attention to and how to map event data
to data that the graph will store in its
database
smart contracts on the blockchain for
those of you coming across the town for
the first time in a nutshell are pieces
of repeatable executable code
they are stored on the blockchain and
run when certain conditions are met
so think if this happens then that
happens you can even think of them as a
sort of function if you wish it could be
to do with releasing money to
stakeholders sending notifications or
anything really all in an encrypted way
when conditions are met smart contracts
can emit events
in fact events are the way you can
communicate with your smart contract in
general so when something happens events
are emitted and loads are written to the
blockchain
that then your front-end applications
can pick up so we know what is going on
once you have defined your subgraph
manifest you can use the graph cli or
command line interface to store the
definitions on the blockchain and tell
the indexer to start indexing data for
that subgraph okay so think what you
want to query define it then run the
indexer and that's it
once you are happy with what you have
built and tested it out to see you are
getting the correct data back you can
publish your sub craft to the
decentralized network
this now means that by using your
subgraph and your definition of it
applications can query data served by
what is called a query market comprised
of a network of indexes or competing to
provide the best indexing service at the
best price
this is opposed to how we query things
today on web 2 which involves going
through a centralized server that just
offers one service at one price
building apps or in this case
decentralized apps also known as the
apps is very different from what we are
used to today
when building on the blockchain as we
touched on briefly already data is not
stored in an organized way it is
scattered all over the place this is
done by design and in layman terms is
the reason it is so secure as it is
decentralized and not reliant on a
centralized source
on the traditional centralized web
databases and apis query filter sort
paginate group and join data before
returning it back to your front-end
applications
usually thanks to some sort of http
request this is possible as data is
organized and indexed on the blockchain
we are missing both these things the
organization and the indexing layer
this would mean that if someone wanted
to build a decentralized app they would
have to build a way to index data by
building and operating proprietary
indexing servers this would require a
lot of time and energy and each company
would probably be doing the same thing
the demand to build a tool that everyone
could use that would also standardize
the way data was queried was that
enter the graph the graph was
essentially born out of this core market
need
today the graph is one of the most used
blockchain protocols and has saved a
number of companies and developers time
and money by building a data querying
tool that they no longer have to build
themselves by now we know why the graph
was invented as well as what we as
developers need to do in order to query
data on the blockchain but how do we
actually do it we have now reached the
practical part of this course so let's
get up our terminals because i'm going
to show you how
first we are going to have to install
the graph cli as this is the main thing
we will need in order to create our
first subgraph so let's jump right into
it and get going
okay so as mentioned before as a
developer we can choose
to either use a sub graph that was
already developed by another developer
or we can make our own so we're going to
make our own
in this tutorial we are going to build a
sub graph for querying nft data from the
foundation smart contract which you can
see
here
we are going to write a query for
fetching nfts as well as their owners
and build relationships between them so
that by the end when we essentially look
all over the ethereum network our data
will come back like
this foundation also has a developer
portal where they have information about
their smart contract code as well as
links to their own sub graphs if you
want to check this out later
so before we get going with this
tutorial
please make sure to have node.js
installed on your machine
here you can find ways to do this and
for this tutorial we are going to be
using nvm to manage node.js versions so
if you don't have those installed please
just go ahead and do that now
gravitate towards this page right here
and just download this onto your machine
as well as nvm like so
so all i'm going to do is just take this
script right here and just put it in my
terminal and run it
okay so once we have these two things
done let's carry on
first off i'm just going to gravitate to
the graph.com
and on here i'm going to select the
drop-down hosted services
once here you have to essentially make
an account i have signed up using my
github account
this has already been done so it's just
going to take me straight to the
platform and i'm going to choose to go
onto my dashboard where you can see some
sub graphs i have already made as
testers as well as my own
now to create our own just go ahead and
click add sub graph right here
we're going to have to name our subgraph
something so because we are working from
the foundation app i'm just gonna call
this foundation app sub graph
and give it a quick subtitle so this can
of course be whatever you wish i'm just
going to fill it out for best practice
and then let's go ahead and leave these
two blank
and then we can fill out a description
and we can give it a github url these
two things are optional please feel free
to fill them out if you wish and just go
ahead and click create graph
and great
now you should be taken to this page
right here with some more steps
the first thing we need to do is
initialize a new subgraph using the
graph cli
so all i'm going to do is view the cli
commands here
so all i'm going to do is view the
commands right here to be able to
install the graph cli
now gravitate to a directory that you
want to work in for me it's going to be
called webstorm projects once again i'm
using npm so i'm going to choose npm
install and i'm going to install it
globally g is for globally and i'm going
to install graph protocol forward slash
graph cli
now i'm going to leave that to run
once that has been installed we can
essentially initialize a new sub graph
with the init command
okay so just go ahead and
wait for that to finish running i might
as well just
zoom this right here so
and once that is done let's just
gravitate to here and i'm just going to
copy the first command that i see
so this command is to initialize a new
sub graph
so all i'm going to do is grab the
command and replace the github name with
my github name and replace this sub
graph name with foundation app subcraft
which is what i called my sub graph
and once again i'm just going to hit
enter on that
now there will be some prompts for you
so just go ahead and make sure to select
the ethereum option
and then on the sub graph name i'm just
going to hit enter i'm happy with that
i'm also happy with
the directory that this wants to be
created in
i'm also happy with the directory it's
going to create my subgraph in so i can
view the code i'm currently once again
in my webstorm projects directory on my
computer
and i'm just gonna hit enter on that
now here please uh select mainnet of
course you can choose whatever you wish
in the future but just for this tutorial
we're gonna be doing on the ethereum
main net
now when i ask for a contract address
this essentially is the contact address
taken from the foundation nft
contract
okay so i have taken this just take the
same one exact same one that you are
seeing here
uh pause if you need to take longer on
this section i'm just gonna go ahead and
click enter for now
and when it next asks you for a contract
name just go ahead and write token
now if we hit enter this command will
essentially generate a basic sub graph
based of the contract address passed
into the argument so all the little
numbers that the contract address it's
going to generate a sub graph for us
based
on
this
okay
so if we now go ahead and look in our
directory we should see a directory
called foundation subgraph that has been
generated for us thanks to the command
above all with the template code that we
need to get started
okay so there is a project for those of
you using vs code you can just open it
up using the command code dot if you
have that installed or you're going to
open up with whatever code edit you wish
i'm going to choose webstorm so i'm just
going to go ahead and find that now
and open it up so
there we go and as you will see in here
there we go there are all our files that
have been generated for us
now i'm going to just go ahead and talk
you through some of these
as we mentioned in the explainer the
subgraph manifest
or in other words how we define our
subgraph manifest is this
subgraph.yaml file
okay so we've talked that one through
once again this is how we define our sub
graph
and next we also have the schema graphql
file which is a graphql schema that
defines what data is stored
for your subgraph and how to query it
via graphql
so at the moment you just see a example
entity that has an id account an owner
and approved so while we are here
actually i'm going to ask you to change
the content of this file to
essentially let us query the nfts in a
way that we want
so
let's go ahead and do that
so all i'm going to do is paste this
piece of code that i have pre-written
here
now let's talk it through a little bit
this is essentially graphql
with graphql we can define entity types
just as we have done here with the type
token and type user
the graph will essentially take this and
generate top level fields for querying
single instances and collections of that
entity type
now this is important each type that
should be an entity is required to be
annotated with an entity directive
so what we are saying is that we want to
index these two entities
okay these two entities that we are
indexing are going to be the token and
the user
this way we can index the tokens created
by the users as well as the users
themselves
what is also interesting is this derived
from right here by adding this derived
from field we can now do reverse lookups
so essentially what is happening is we
are creating a virtual field on the
entity that may be queried but cannot be
set manually through the mappings api
rather it is derived from the
relationship defined on the other entity
for such relationships it rarely makes
sense to store both sides of the
relationship and both indexing and query
performance will be better when only one
site is stored and the other is derived
okay great so now that we have defined
our schema essentially for the entities
we can generate the entities locally
with one simple command we're going to
use the command graph cogent in order to
spin up some code so let's just go ahead
and do that
and now if we look in the ts file some
code would have been generated for us
based on the two schema that we wrote
if you haven't come across this command
before this command essentially
generates assembly script types from a
combination of the subgraphs graphql
schema and the contract abas included in
the data sources
by using this command we are essentially
making everything type safe
now let's move on to the subgraph jam of
file we're going to have to update some
things based on what we have just done
so the first thing i'm going to ask you
to do is just head over to the data
sources mapping entities
and just add the user and the token
entities just like so
next up let's move on to the data
sources mapping event handlers and i'm
gonna actually get rid of all these
event handlers as we don't need them
anymore that was just the template code
and i'm just gonna add these two events
right here along with these two handlers
make sure to keep the indentation the
exact same as this will cause issues for
you if you don't
and finally we need to update the
configuration to add the start block and
change the contract address to the main
proxy contract address
so once again i am just going to use
this right here make sure to use the
exact same as me
now go ahead and open up the source
mappings ts file where we're going to
write the mappings that we defined in
our sub graph sub graph event handlers
so once again i have pre-done this for
you and we're just going to get rid of
all this code all of this template code
and make it reflect what we want which
is the token and the user schemas and
here is the code so once again if you
need this i will be putting this in the
description below this is a great
template for you to have
now these mappings will essentially
handle events for when a new token is
created transferred or updated
when these events fire the mappings will
save the data into the subgraph
and there we go we are all done
now let's run a build so we're going to
do this using the build command like so
making sure that we are definitely in
the project that we need to be
and
next we are going to have to go back
here and run the following command of
the deploy section of the tutorial
so all i'm going to do is grab this
command
graph off and once again i'm just going
to replace the necessary fields
so this time i'm going to need the
access token which is going to be unique
to you and you can find it right here
and i'm just going to run that command
now we're just going to have to wait for
that to do its thing and finally i'm
just going to grab this command to
deploy our graph
making sure to once again replace the
github name and the sub graph name so
this is my github name please go ahead
and use your own and whatever you called
your sub graph just make sure that is
the same and run the command
and there we have it we have deployed
our sub graph you can see it here and
then if you go back to your dashboard
you will see these subgraphs show up
right
there
wonderful so once we have that we have
deployed our subgraph it is now time to
start querying the foundation app nft
space to see if we can return back nfts
as well as their owners ids and so on
so
let's do it
so this should spin up a playground
similar to probably ones you've seen
before if you have used graphql before
as you will see there are some schemas
on the right you will see the other
schemes that we defined so the token
schema and the user schema that we can
use now to write our queries
a query has been generated for us also
the example query so if i click this
button right here
it will
run
and you will see the uris for the
content as well as the token ids and the
token ipfs paths
so
wonderful
this is looking good
now let's try write our own query so i'm
going to do this from scratch and i can
also use the schema to help me do this
so for example if i want to query tokens
these are the things that i can get
returned back to me
so i'm just going to go ahead and start
doing this now this is the syntax for
querying things using graphql
so i just want to return back tokens
like so
and the tokens that i want to return
well i want to get back each token's id
as you can see here
as well as each tokens
token id which is a different type of id
and i also want to pick out the token
ipfs path
so
as you can see we don't need to pick all
the fields these are the only three that
i want to return
so i can literally pick and choose what
i want returned i could have picked the
owner i could have picked the creator i
could have put the timestamp i could
have put the name but i have just chosen
these three
and if we run that
there we
go
another neat thing that can be done is
that i can order
the order in which i want these tokens
to come back to me in so if i want to do
this all i have to do is write the order
by and order it by the id
as well as add an order direction so
making sure that is in between two
parenthesis i'm going to choose the
order direction to be descending and if
i run this
you will see the token id starts at
99999
and if i go ahead and put ascending so
asc for ascending it will start at 1.
so there we go
let's just change that back to
descending maybe for now i can also skip
the first 100
so for example if i put skip 100 just
like so and run this then the first 100
tokens will be skipped
great
now let's perhaps look at the users so
once again i'm just going to use this
syntax to return back the users
and if we have a look at the schema we
can see that we can choose the id
the tokens and because we have derived
this i can now use
the token schema to get back
tokens
okay so hopefully you can see what we
have done there with the derived from
tag that you saw earlier i am
essentially using the user token schema
and i've now sort of made a relationship
between the token schema and the user
schema
so now once again i can choose to
order the tokens just like we did before
and this time perhaps let's do it by the
timestamp so i could just choose create
it at timestamp option
and wonderful
please do have a go around our playing
here before moving on to the next
section
in this part of the tutorial i'm going
to be showing you how to build a front
end using react quickly in order to
display the data in our browsers
so all the data that you see here i'm
going to be showing you how to get it to
here
okay
so let's get to it super simple let's do
it
if you do not know react or would like
to use some sort of other framework for
the front end please feel free but
please do have a go at watching long
anyway to get the general concepts
the two packages that we are going to
need for this part of the tutorial are
oracle and graphql you will see them
right here
aqua allows us to rapidly use graphql in
our applications without complex
configuration or large api overhead
and the graphql package will allow us to
write queries in this format right here
in our front end
so to get going we're going to have to
grab our query http path
in fact if you would like to actually
use any of the sub graphs you can go
ahead and do so so i'm just going to
show you how to do that before moving on
so right on here just select the graph
explorer and we can choose any of these
really so perhaps let's go ahead and
choose the art blocks one and then you
will be able to view the query the url
query that you will need so for example
to use art blocks i would need to get
this query url
okay
and that's really it
so now that we know that let's go ahead
and get our own query url from the
subgraph we have made
so i'm just going to gravitate back to
my dashboard where we made the
foundation app sub graph
and i'm just going to go ahead and click
on it and here we go here is my query
url that is the url that i need to make
the queries
so just make a mental note of that now
let's get to creating our frontend app
so all i'm going to do is once again
gravitate to my websome projects and in
this directory i'm going to use the
command npx create react app and then
whatever i want to call my app so i'm
just going to call it my graph studio in
order to spin up i react out fast with
configuration with files so everything
will essentially be done for me if you
want to read more about this command
please go ahead and check it out here
it is one that i use often my project so
that we can get to the coding part
quickly
so once this has finished running at the
moment it's just getting all the
necessary files i need and all the
configuration then we should get ready
to start our project
and
there we go
we are now done so now i just need to go
into the project i made so i called it
my graph project so i'm going to go into
there and i now need to install the
packages that i discussed so erco
and graphql
and i'm just going to wait for those to
install and i'm just going to open up my
project so once again i am using
webstorm so i'm just going to open up
webstorm again and there you will see
foundation up subgraph that we made in
the last section and i'm just going to
open up the newest directory that we
have made which is called my graph
project
and in here ta-da
you will see all the files necessary to
get going with create react app
so i'm not going to talk you through
these hopefully you know this command
already
and now to start the app
i'm just going to use the command npm
run start like so
and that will spin up my app on
localhost 3000
there we go this is what it should look
like
now if we look back in our projects and
check out the package json you will see
the oracle package and you will also see
the graph your package along with their
version so if anything is not working
for you right now it could be because
you're using a newer version if that is
so just revert back to this version and
run npmi so npm install again to
reinstall all these packages
okay
let's move on
now the first thing i'm going to do is
just in the app.js file i'm going to
import create client from arco so the
package that we just installed
and i'm also going to import use effect
and use state from react
okay so those are literally the only
three things we need
now even though we are not importing
graphql here we still do need it so
don't think that that was installed
without a reason next i'm going to put
my url in here so the query url i'm
going to save it in this project let's
save it as const url and let's just go
ahead and grab it so i'm just going to
get that here and just paste it as a
string like so
the next thing we need to do is use our
query so i'm going to
define this as query and i am going to
put some backticks in here because we
need the backsticks in order for this to
work and i'm just going to get this
query the example query that we have in
our playground okay if i run it it
should return this data so that's the
data that i want returned so let's grab
it and let's just paste it in our
project like so so super simple
there we go
the next thing that i want to do is
actually start a client so let's define
our client and i'm going to use create
client that we imported from the package
aqua
and then we're just going to pass
through the url maybe let's call this
something different i'm going to call
this api url like so
and the next thing that i'm going to do
is just fetch the data
so for this i'm going to write a
function
it's called fetch data and it's an async
function and in here i'm going to use
the client that i defined and i'm going
to use query which is a method that
comes with it and pass through the query
and then use the method to promise on it
so again this is just the query that we
have defined and i'm going to await this
and then catch the response once it
resolves so once the promise resolves
and i'm just going to console.log it out
so we can see it in our browser
now this function i'm going to put in a
use effect so just go ahead and do that
in order for this to work
and let's check it out
so now if i inspect the browser
you should see a response with the
object which has the data and the tokens
and the users coming back to me okay so
exactly the same as we saw on our
playground we are now seeing this in our
browser
wonderful
okay so this is pretty much it if you
want to actually see in the browser as
well i'm just going to quickly show you
how to do that maybe let's just show
the content uri and the token id
so all i'm going to do is just save the
tokens to state
we can do this using
use state or the use state react hook
so let's go ahead and do that now const
tokens and then set tokens and i'm going
to start off with state being null so at
the moment tokens is null and we're
going to use set tokens in order to
change the value of tokens to something
else
so i am now going to get the response
data tokens because we just want the
tokens really and i'm going to use set
tokens in order to change the value of
tokens
to the tokens that are coming back to us
with the response
and once again we want to display this
in the browser so i'm just going to get
rid of all this template code
and if tokens exist i want to map each
token
once again we need the index as well
because we're going to have to add a key
to the wrapping div
so let's make a wrapping div and then
just pass through the key of
index and we're not using it so i'm just
gonna
put in a little underscore like so
and
now
we are gonna have to i'm gonna make
these
uh
a tags and if we click on them it's
gonna take us to the
token content uri it's gonna open up a
new new tab
and then perhaps let's also have the
let's have the token id
so ta-da
now if we click on the token
uri it will take us to all of this
information here this is pretty neat
and then we can also see our token id
next to it
wonderful so we're getting the data back
we're displaying of course please be
more inventive feel free to display your
data however you wish this is
essentially the steps into getting that
data showing up on your front end if you
want to use perhaps a different sub
graph that might come back with
different data you can use in different
ways as well so the world is really your
oyster with this
okay
so we've covered a lot so far now the
final part is going to be all about
managing your api keys and billing for
your studio so we're just going to head
over to the sub graph studio by
navigating here
now the first thing that you are going
to need is to have a wallet set up i'm
going to be using metamask for this
tutorial so i'm just going to show you
quickly how to get set up so i'm just
going to show you quickly how to get set
up with metamask just in case that you
haven't before
first off just gravitate towards
metamaster io and simply install the
chrome extension once that is done you
should see a little fox show up here and
if you click on it this browser should
show up
now let's go ahead and click get started
as we are new i'm going to go ahead and
create a new wallet and just go through
these steps
go ahead and create your password making
sure that is unique to you
finally after clicking next you're going
to get some secret recovery phrases
these are super important don't disclose
them to anyone i'm going to be sharing
them with you here as my wallet is not
going to be active so here are my secret
words and i'm just going gonna have to
confirm my secret recovery phrases by
dragging and dropping them in the
correct order so once again do not save
this with anyone keep it super safe as
if anyone has this they will be able to
access your wallet
and there we go
so that is it we are now set up i have a
metamask wallet let's continue
so now it's going to prompt me to
connect with my wallet i am going to go
ahead and do that and my wallet should
pop up in the corner like
so
and there we go
super simple
just go ahead and click next through
these and once we are done go ahead and
click on the billing tab
here you will see your billing balance
as well as any costs that you have
incurred in the billing period
now to enable billing this is important
you must have ether
and grt in your metamask wallet so these
two things are important in order to get
set up
this is what your dashboard should look
like if they are it should give you the
option to deposit grt to your billing
balance billing is covered on the matic
side chain in order to decrease
transaction times as well as transaction
costs
in this step we are going to move grt to
the matic network so i'm just going to
put in the value of 25 and approve and
confirm
once the grt is successfully moved to
the matic network we can now switch to
thematic network
to view more details on the matic
network please visit
docs.medic.network forward slash docs
develop network details network as you
can see in the url right here
here you'll see the details that we need
to import into our metamask wallet
including the network name the chain id
and the rpc address
so now let's go ahead and add that to
our metamask wallet so i'm just going to
click on settings and gravitate towards
networks and now we're going to manually
add the network so once again i'm just
going to add the network name the chain
id
and the rpc
once the network is configured in your
metamask wallet we can now move on to
the next step
we can now move our grt from our wallet
balance into our billing balance
so let's just go ahead and confirm this
add grt and confirm
and great you will see our billing
balance has been updated
after all these steps have been taken we
are now ready to create our api key
so all i'm going to do is gravitate
towards the api key drop drop-down and
i'm simply going to create an api key
so we can obviously rename it here and
let's go ahead once our new api key is
created we can now scope it down to
authorized subgraphs and authorized
domains to scope an api key to a
subgraph we first need the sub graph id
subgrave ids can be found here so just
go ahead and find the subgraph id you
need so this one right here
and paste it like so
and there we go so the whole reason we
did this is so that we are now enabled
to use the pull together sub graph okay
we are now authorized to use it thanks
to this api key
and there we have it we have now
finished the tutorial all about querying
on the blockchain
so in conclusion what we have learnt is
how to build sub graphs how to hook up a
front end to use our sub graph and then
how to manage our api keys and billing
thanks so much for watching and i'll see
you again soon